il s'appelle eric pire qui il arrive de
2019 sa merde c'est jane birkin son père
vous allez bientôt savoir qu'il sait il
est ce un thésard il vient de gagner un
oscar pour son premier film de synthèse
voici d'eric berck et
enfin soirée est ce que tu as fait bon
voyage super gt en train de bosser là
juste avant et c'est pas tout à coup je
me suis sentie a pris dans une espèce de
grande tunnel de lumière
j'étais pas mal c'est 'qui c'est une
truc assez yellow finalement yellow oui
yellow ça veut dire c'est une expression
à la mode ça veut dire délirant foot us
et ce à cause du tube d elton john
sister's c'est une groupe du cinglé
d'euros glasgow je passe tu connais pas
du tout tu pas elle parle pas du tout
moyon né en 1994 connais pas bien encore
ça oui et tu view mais je vis à londres
ni oui tu es moins l'accent que ta mère
tu trouves
oui un peu moins ah ouais je sais pas un
moment père y trouve que j'ai une pointe
d'accent mais je ce qui tend vers la
tension c'est nicolas sarkozy nicolas
sarkozy oui bah c'est à dire qu'ils sont
connus en 81 en août 94 justement dans
la maison de louise et jacques toubon
oui ils sont ministres lui est pas et
surtout les deux ministres de la culture
ben voilà c'est ça ouais ouais ouais ils
se sont connus là-bas j'en ai eu une
histoire d'amour ils ont une histoire
d'amour l'année d'après je suis né donc
c'était l'été 94 parce que là pour le
moment dans la vraie vie sans toujours
pas ensemble ah oui mais je ne sais pas
mais tu sais la suite ils se sont
séparés mais enfin je veux dire ils sont
restés en bons termes je vois ils sont
pas ouais cool tu as quel âge mais je
vais avoir 25 ans là au mois d'octobre
et ta mère elle a fait quoi depuis
depuis 1994 depuis maintenant moi oui
tenir jeudi et aujourd'hui elle fait
quoi
ben écoute beaucoup de choses là fait
beaucoup de cinéma comme réalisatrice en
france et en angleterre en australie
aussi elle a réalisé une dizaine de
films dont
le plus connu c'est à l'évangile selon
saint serge
ouais et
elle a été présidente du comité de
survie du cinéma européen mais bon
pendant la négociation en 2004 elle a
traité les représentants américains de
petits trous du cul d'accord et ça ça a
été la fin de sa carrière la tête du
comité tu vois mais elle n'a pas
enregistré d'album depuis un moment et
ça ça fait 20 ans que les producteurs
l'emmerdent pour qu'elle réagisse une
disque qu'elle va peut-être accepter
cette année pour fêter ses 75 ans je
sais pas il tempère nicolas sarkozy il a
fait quoi lui depuis 1994 dans le 94 95
je crois il était juste après les
élections
qu'est-ce qui a gagné les
présidentielles en 95 bah mon parrain
balladur et tonton quand quand balladur
a été élu président de la république oui
ton père il a été nommé ministre de quoi
eh ben il a été nommé d'abord ministre
du budget et après il a été premier
ministre et c'était un après tu sais 98
quand ça a été le départ en fanfare de
pasquale les coups tordus qui a eu avec
chirac que chirac a fait des coups
tordus à balladur ouais ouais des coups
tordus il a été obligé de descendre des
missions c'était normal ça a été très
dur
et tu sais je veux dire il a mis du
temps à remonter la pente parce qu'à
l'époque il disait je suis une femme
muse de droite a alors forcément je vais
me longtemps remonter la pente
bah oui c'est vrai il a il est
aujourd'hui il fait une présidente du
mouvement européen pour le progrès et
surtout dirige le centre aussi européen
pour la paix dans les balkans tu sais
c'est une sujet qui lui tient vraiment à
coeur
surtout depuis les massacres des
sarajevo en 2014
alliant corrida grâce à ça continue
c'est nul nul ça continue tu vois il toi
tu es santé has
alors c'est quoi ce désastre oui c'est
le réalisateur de film de synthèse si tu
préfères c'est comme tu l'as dit j'ai
obtenu un oscar à hollywood il ya dix
jours c'est particulièrement important à
la joie qu'on peut l'applaudir
c'est la première fois
c'est la première fois qu'un film de
synthèse
d'ailleurs son sommet
on obtient un oscar à hollywood quand
même là c'est merveilleux alors j'aime
bien commencer spatiale n'y a pas de
comédien c'est là que les tous les
comédiens sont redessinés oui c'est ça
ça veut dire que même les voix elles
sont des voix de synthèse pas voulu
m'emmerder tu vois avec les états d'âme
des de savoir s'il allait bien s'il
n'allait pas bien on perd un temps fou
que ça va vous savez on ne peut pas
travailler dans des conditions comme ça
c'est marrant que tu dises ça avec une
mère comédienne que toi tu dises que tu
veux pas tomber relais avec les
comédiens avec les états d'âme des
comédiens bah oui je sais pas et ton
enfant s'est passé comment pas mal
c'était ma soeur charlotte plutôt qui
s'est occupé du moins tu vas pas mal
juste que son mariage avec eux les devis
de chance elle qui est le fils de chez
la psy vous dire que charlotte
gainsbourg a épousé le welsh et la wii
s'est marié en 2005 je crois et leur
départ aux states parce qu'ils sont
partis là bas mais aussi mon oui j'ai eu
mon parrain edouard bien sûr qui s'est
vachement occupé des mois parce que tu
sais qu'il a toujours été vachement
proche des jeunes oui oui ça on voit
bien tout faire de très bons l'atelier
pas vraiment non les chaînes de
rencontres m'amuse pas mal oui c'est
vrai des chaînes de rencontre c'est quoi
ben les gens ce film et communiquent en
direct toute la nuit dans ces vachement
bien parce que c'est vrai je veux dire
c'est une truite encore hyper yellow
parce que c'est une sorte de grand
bordel organisé
tu vois les gens ont peur du sida tu
sais aujourd'hui il ya quasiment je veux
dire on attribue qu'on a trouvé le
le vaccin c'est fini ça à part quelques
vieux qui là encore c'est terminé mais
c'était quoi le remède contre le sida
je sais pas si on me demande ça moi je
suis pas toubib je peux pas te dire
c'est qu'ils les stars en 2019 va écoute
charlotte gainsbourg
ouais c'est logique et non dans les
jeunes français j'aime bien comment il
s'appelle paris devait label crown et
louisa mousse bruel c'est la fille tu
sais que patrick qu'il a eu avec romane
et la mode pour autant une oreille doit
être doré la sécu est ça si tu veux
c'est une truc qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
on a on a besoin de valoriser le corps
de le considérer finalement commun comme
un bijou
ouais c'est plus qu'une mode quoi je
veux dire c'est un mouvement
philosophique parce que qui dit que le
corps une bijou absolu est parfait qui
on doit le mettre en valeur le magnifier
et le nez par exemple on peut se dorer
le nez oui on peut tu peux te donnerai
tout ce que tu veux tu de drogue
toi tu pose toujours les mêmes questions
c'est vrai je me rends compte que
j'avais vu sur le cas bien passé il n'y
a pas longtemps un émission de t ancien
à lunettes noires lunettes noires le jeu
tout qu'est ce que tu faisais là dans
les années risque et main de 81,80 et si
tu veux là je me suis rendu compte que
c'était encore les mêmes questions se
posent toujours les questions sur le
drogue et c'est sur ça et sur le cul je
me suis dit moi il ya que la drogue il
ya que le cul de chenôve qui t'intéresse
et c'est tout quoi mais moi je prends
juste l'extrait de nicotine pour
travailler quand même nom lâchez pas
j'ai laissé au bureau j'ai sur moi merde
tu veux qu'on écoute une chanson de ta
merde
et pourquoi depuis le début j'ai à
chaque fois qu'il parle de référence à
m'emmerder la surprend l'accent encore
là tu es comme les espagnols quand il se
met en colère la surprend complètement
l'accent de ta merde non non je sais pas
mais tu continues à me parler mon merde
là quand tu t'énerves c'est carrément le
portrait de ta mère écoutant l
impression de voir ta mère je sais pas
quand je ne fais pas exprès c'est vrai
peut-être que c'est quelque chose comme
ça qui manque
écoute tu me parles de ça tu veux pas de
gainsbourg gainsbourg c'est un type moi
je n'ai même pas connu quand je suis né
il était déjà morte
c'est vrai
et en tirer depuis longtemps bon bon moi
j'ai galéré j'aime bien ça fait dix ans
je galère j'ai fait des je fais des
films avec des bouts débout comme ça que
j'ai rajouté avec rien du tout je galère
pour imposer un style tu me parle même
pas de ça on en parle à peine c'est vrai
merde mais ça c'est des talk-shows la
télévision non je veux dire tu me parles
tu m'emmerdes tout le temps moi j'ai
quand même eu un oscar
il m'en fallait la honte pour un parti
mais eric si tu veux on reçoit les gens
je ne veux pas prescrit à la télévision
j'ai pas trop qu'est ce que tu veux je
veux dire moi je viens ici pour parler
de ça me parle pas alors moi je vais le
casser ça comme ça à tokyo et à chaque
fois c'est pareil on a fait les mêmes
goûts moi je peux plus je suis sur un
cinq shows aériens coeur bon dominique
je sais pas moi il s'est cassé qu'est ce
que tu veux que je te dise moi dites
donc c'est terry là il ya un truc ça
serait sympa que vos invités et je
déballais 10e commande vous dites et
maria claria les dématérialise
d'ailleurs dans mon couloir parce que le
fils à la limande la pièce
dématérialisée dans mon collègue m'a
foutu du doré par tout autre
mais la menora les vélos fous l'oreille
de pied maintenant ça suffit
qui alors s'il vous plaît surveillance
et sa vaillance à ça va comme ça c'est
assez chiant petit et matérialisant le
couloir et avec valve des maternités
dans les bateyes pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu